et is taking a look at the royal
highlights from week 1 of Megan Markel
and Prince Harry's 16 day tour of
Australia New Zealand Tonga and Fiji
it's been amazing starting with the
pregnancy reveal one step at a time and
most artists found me shortly after the
Duke and Duchess of Sussex touched down
in Sydney on Tuesday Kensington Palace
announced that the couple is expecting
their first child
we also generally couldn't think of a
better place to announce the upcoming
baby beard a boy or girl so thank you
very very much
Harry addressed their unborn baby for
the first time that night and if that
didn't make you tear up his feet at the
2018 Invictus games opening ceremonies
on Saturday is bound to do the trick I
want to say something directly to our
hosts the people of Australia first of
all thank you for the welcome you have
given Megan and I over the last few days
I have been so proud to be able to
introduce my wife to you
and we have been so happy to be able to
celebrate the personal joy of our newest
addition with you all and while an
expectant Megan started the royal tour
off strong she has reportedly decided to
cut back on her schedule and is healing
fine but resting
the parents-to-be have been showered
with gifts and had tons of adorable
parenting practice law Perry even
admitted he hoped that they're having a
girl during an exchange with one
onlooker in Sydney it's a new chapter
right
Megan's estranged father Thomas Markel
also shared well wishes on the royal
family addition in a new interview with
The Mail on Sunday
Marko's said he learned his daughter was
expecting thanks to a radio report he
told the outlet quote I was filled with
love joy and happiness for both my
beautiful daughter and my son-in-law a
new baby is a blessing and I look
forward to seeing a little Megan or a
little hairy butt oh and all the land
down under has given us a ton of sweet
moments Megan and Harry have met some
cuddly animals they've gotten fancy and
they protected each other every step of
the way
Harry was reacquainted with his
favourite Aussie ninety eight year old
war Widow Daphne done plus he got to
introduce her to his wife and the Duke
and Duchess got laid we're talking the
flower variety as they hit one of
Australia's most famous landmarks Bondi
Beach to talk about mental health
awareness the parents-to-be were all
smiles photons even caught this glimpse
of Megan cradling her tiny baby bomb
we're a fantastic team we know real
making in Harry also visited a girls
high school to talk about youth
empowerment it was on this stop that
Megan revealed her first job included
taking out the trash and did we mention
Prince Harry climbed the Sydney Harbour
Bridge to kick off the Invictus games
that's a whopping thirteen hundred and
thirty two step climb of course the
annual event holds extra significance
for Megan and Harry it was at last
year's Invictus games in Canada that
they made their first official
parents together